even with political divisions across the
country 46 states have joined the
government's groundbreaking legal
challenge to facebook
two antitrust lawsuits accuse the
world's biggest social network of
illegally
shutting down the competition now if
these lawsuits
succeed facebook may have to sell two of
its most popular apps
jeff begays has more on this story
the federal trade commission is asking
for a federal court
to force facebook to sell off assets
like instagram and whatsapp
arguing that in acquiring those
competitors facebook illegally created a
monopoly
today's enforcement action aims to
restore competition to this important
industry
and provide a foundation for future
competitors to grow
and to innovate without the threat of
being crushed by facebook
facebook shot back calling the ftc's
lawsuit
revisionist history saying the
commission cleared these acquisitions
years ago
the government now wants a do-over
sending a chilling warning to american
business that no
sale is ever final but it's not just the
ftc
that has its eye on facebook on
wednesday a bipartisan group of
attorneys
general from nearly every u.s state
filed its own lawsuit against facebook
accusing the company of predatory
behavior
back in july ceo mark zuckerberg
defended facebook's acquisition of
instagram
which it bought for one billion dollars
in 2012.
the ftc had all of these documents and
reviewed this and unanimously voted
at the time not to challenge the
acquisition facebook has acquired about
70 companies over the past 15 years
and since facebook acquired instagram
and whatsapp
both platforms have become far more
popular
and help facebook reach its current
value of nearly
800 billion dollars for cbs this morning
jeff begays in washington